so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
solve for the missing angle now and the
way you do that is you want to position
yourself over here at the angle that
you're interested in okay and you figure
out what's the size that you have okay
in this case we have the opposite side
and we have the adjacent side and you
can see that's tangent tangents the
opposite over the adjacent tangents
opposite over adjacent so what we're
gonna do is we're going to set up an
equation
okay tangent of angle axe equals the
opposite side over the adjacent side
it's always going to be the second over
the third letter in this acronym okay
and what we're going to do now we want
to solve for X so what we're going to do
is we're going to do the tan inverse
okay
of both sides the tangent inverse of
both sides so you can see Tan inverse
and tangent we get our angle by itself
it's the tangent inverse of 8/10 okay
let's go to the calculator and see what
that is so we've got tan inverse of 8/10
I'm getting thirty eight point seven
degrees
okay so this is thirty eight point seven
okay so let's take a look at the next
one so here we want to figure out what
ratio we need to work with to solve for
angle y so you can see you've got the
opposite side and the hypotenuse so
which trig ratio is that the sine see
opposite over hypotenuse sine is
opposite over hypotenuse so we're going
to do is we're going to do the same
thing we're going to say sine of angle y
equals the opposite okay which is four
over the hypotenuse which is seven I'm
going to take the sine inverse okay of
both sides okay
these are inverses they cancel one
another out we get the angle by itself
and Y is the sine inverse of 4/7 so you
can do that on your calculator it's you
just sometimes you have to use the
second key it's right above the sine
you'll see this -1 it means the inverse
okay the last one we're going to solve
for angle Z what trig function
together the adjacent side see how it's
next to and the hypotenuse
see how it's across from the right angle
okay so adjacent and hypotenuse that's
the cosine so cosine is the adjacent
side over the hypotenuse so let's go
ahead and set that cosine Z equals x
over 12 and to solve for Z we're going
to take the cosine inverse of both sides
so that's x over 12 now you can see here
in this problem I didn't tell you what X
is
but let's just say for example x equals
9 then we could put 9 in here and we can
solve for angle Z so when you do these
trig ratios this is good that this came
up because you need to know two of the
three quantities to solve for that third
missing quantity if you have more than
one variable with these ratios you won't
be able to solve it okay so this is how
you work with the inverse trig functions
if you're getting something out of these
videos as I hope you are subscribe to
the channel and I've got some more
videos coming for you so I look forward
to seeing you in some of the future
videos